what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am about to do a first
time watching for a movie that has been
at the top of my list for months now
just haven't found quite the right time
to do it then I saw that they are doing
an adaptation of I think the Broadway
musical version so I thought like oh now
is the time
to do some SEO game here and finally
watch a movie that has literally been
the first title I see out of all these
movies I haven't watched yet and that is
the color purple I've heard good things
about it I've heard Whoopi Goldberg is
great in it despite whatever Twitter
controversy she's always in I've heard
of that uh Oprah is also great in it
Steven Spielberg movie
um but I've never seen a moving frame of
it once in my life and for a ride it's
like two and a half hours long hope it's
a good one so the ladies and gentlemen
if you could leave a like I know you can
that'd be very much appreciated also uh
subscribe and click that notification
Bell we are covering so many movies on
this channel happy to have you along the
journey to become part of the reject
Nation as always full-length and watch
along is where you single with your own
copy of The Color Purple I am watching
this off of Max today uh is available
for our super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page we cover a whole bunch of
stuff exclusively over there as well
with reaction highlights and watch Longs
included let's get into the swing of
things people
[Music]
Earth conditions in this time this
weather
you better not never tell nobody but God
you'll kill your Mama wait what let's
get rid of the baby I got two children
but my daddy a baby boy called Adam he
took while sleeping and a baby girl
called Olivia that's my wife's name I
don't think he killed my little baby boy
I heard he sold it to a preacher and his
wife just sold the baby he come home
with a girl from around a town called
gray she'd be almost my age
but they can't marry now my little
sister Nettie she's got a man always
looking at her damn young Danny Glover
he got three children though he seen Ned
in church and I every Sunday evening
Here Come mister Tammy he'll be smiling
I'm so used to associating him from
Lethal Weapon get old is anyhow she want
to marry first that sucks she ain't
fresh though but I expect you know that
you're spoiled
twice oh let me see you again
turn around
what's he doing that for your sister's
thinking about marriage bass tank lover
seems like a real creep I don't cry I
lived there thinking about Nettie and
then I think about that pretty woman in
the picture I know what he doing to me
he died to her and maybe she like it
really disturbing surprise this is PG-13
is this just about this woman surviving
this very abusive lifestyle maybe it's
my preconceived notion because I'm
familiar with Schindler's List that I
wasn't expecting this to have a bit of a
Hollywood gloss to it feels less raw
Spielberg and more Robert zimecus I
think
[Music]
Jesus Danny Glover's definitely the
villain of this movie other than the
general world I'm gonna make me and my
little girl a new dress come out louder
would you like yes
now run away is she my baby her name
Olivia
Pauline well but I call her Olivia what
so definitely is Olivia
oh unless it's just a massive
coincidence just
left so I call her old Olivia wow this
is really sad
because the Candy stay with us for a
spell oh god what happened with you and
Paul I just couldn't keep him off me you
gotta fight
got all I know how to do is stay alive
that's what she's gonna learn in this
story
it's a beautiful shot finding light in
the Darkness
you are nailing it yo these two little
girls are great
I gotta go to school no
oh my God
[Music]
damn this [__] is so horrifying
oh my God
oh that's so mean
[Music]
these little girls are like so good come
on girl cause I'm waiting for you
you cut me and I'll kill you man just go
right for the slice
cut his third and run
[Music]
man his offspring must be terrible I
think another place is sort of like a
taunting boyish bully don't let me get
ready yeah
what's up huh yes okay nothing's really
changed huh
she says she right but she never right
she said only death could keep her from
it maybe she did oh so she hasn't heard
from her in this entire time
oh [__]
Sophia Sophia Sophia
that's Oprah I'm living with
him with her husband and they say I can
live with him for the rest of my life
hell yeah oh I love her humble don't you
move
One Step just don't make me wait too
long Harpo Papa
oh Harpo
I won't
I will I will I do
[Laughter]
you mean now salute the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I guess we don't have to worry
about Harpo being like his dad unless
this movie proves me way wrong
do it better than a good sound beaten
Sophia thinks too much of herself needs
to be taken down a pig or two ask Harpo
what I'm gonna do about Sophia
oh she just breaks my heart man
damn
Ita
whoa
you told Harpo to beat me
it wasn't Mew
out of Northfield and the mule just went
crazy he started kicking
oh my life are here to fight I never
thought I had to fight in my own house
Sophia beat on Harper then Harper beat
on Sofia and then one day Sophia she
just can't take it no more
good good for
oh
the woman that should have been your
Mammy should Avery the hell is going on
I need to see our eyes then my feet can
let go of the spot they stuck in you
show is ugly
jeez everyone's so goddamn meaner
in the in the cooler on the Shelf ain't
warm enough how you work the stove huh
yeah they become a real adult huh
assistant
this this cruel narcissistic prick
nicely done very good job
scared of her
I just stand back and I wait to see what
the wall gonna look like
who exactly is this shook person
who you
silly man you ain't well mind your own
goddamn business I feel just fine just
had to eat has she not left this room
yo Paul love you my boss still love me
except you don't know it
some real fascinating subject matter in
this
he is so much taller than him just
couldn't rest till you got her in your
house could you dancer it really does
play like a little boy huh my own Daddy
won't even have nothing to do with him
oh Mr talking trash about sugar folks
don't like nobody being too proud or Too
free
slowly standing up I love Chuck Avery
you're all our children's got different
daddies oh she'll Gabriel's children got
the same Daddy I can voucher for nothing
silly you as my sympathy
little bit of satisfaction
foreign
after he leave the field he knocking
down and piling things up sometimes his
friends Swain come by to help Lawrence
Fishman hey hobo
hey
[Music]
it's pretty cool you could build it
she just sees a lot of women that she
wishes she could be like huh
that's all I'm about to sing is called
Mercedes Blues
what because she scratches out my head
when I was healing
oh all eyes on her I did not see this
coming
[Music]
too
foreign
[Music]
yes
we sure ain't got a whole lot of times
[Music]
is feeling fine
this whole movie
no it wasn't Power Rangers
so nice
[__] humiliating this [__] out of
Albert too if everyone knows what's up
[Laughter]
I believe I want me some of this here I
want to introduce y'all to my friend
Henry broad next that Albert guy is so
pathetic
[Music]
I love her to dispatch she's so good
she best to leave you alone is it magic
John
you said someone get a main dance with
his wife if it wants to
never officially filed for divorce
you're just a bigger
like I said talking to the raw woman
like that man with me
oh no
Lord have mercified
oh hell yeah only one developing a
relationship with sugar Avery
[Laughter]
for me to go what you beat me when you
ain't here
why you do that
you beat me for not being you
oh
all right that's some truth you still
love me
I got what you call passion for
do you mind if I ever sleep with me
you like sleeping with him
just climb on top of me do his business
let me see what you sound like he going
to the toilet on you he does the ball
his [__] on her don't nobody love me I
love you you think that's ugly no I
don't I think you beautiful
oh [__] what's going on am I late to
pick it up on some cues here I think I'm
late to pick it up on some cues here
foreign
woman
there's like so much pain even in her
Smile and now she's on The View always
getting in trouble
is that her paw I couldn't sleep
at night
I was wondering why
Jesus mean
man the men in this movie
suck
I'ma go with her
this is my only chance to break from Mr
jail
what you doing
how's he always sneak up on her
way
oh my God
I was gonna miss you too Miss Seeley
Chicago
jeez Ed
so can you give me some sugar
would you like to work for me
hell no
what did you say
what did she say she said hell no what
did you say to miss Millie I said hell
oh hell no
oh
[Music]
after many years they let Sophia out of
jail just to put in the next
wow she ended up being Miss Millie made
after all may have bought Miss Miller a
new car and she don't answer fear to
teach her how to drive it
wow
Mr Hamilton nice to see you I hope you
folks have a nice Christmas this year
well thank you very much
have you ever thought about going to
Mars wow
so it's not as abusive but she still
seems insufferable I'm gonna drive you
home tomorrow
I God
oh boy
hi my name is Emma
I'm very pleased to meet you
I'm just gonna only let her have a day
[Music]
cause I don't know y'all no more oh
I can do it I can put this thing in
reverse and I can make it go the right
way
woman stop driving man
oh that's my sister so that's a squeeze
in
I don't know her either
these adults false sense of care
[__]
man that is messed up
I've heard so much about you feels like
we all friends
her husband
this is my husband
yikes
[Music]
come on Miss Haley go upstairs with me
okay I gotta finish stuff in the turkey
has her sister been riding this whole
time
I've been writing to you over the years
but I Albert said you'd never hear from
me again and since I never heard from
you all this time I guess he was right
wow Albert
oh you deserve to be castrated
one thing I want you to know
I love you
and I'm not
dead
man it's been so many years
the lady you met in town is named
Corrine they could not have chillins and
then they say
God sent them Olivia oh
and Adam
ah they say they stayed together the
children huh and now God has sent me to
watch over them to Lavish all the love I
feel for you on them wow
it's pretty crazy
and your sister
good
morning go find them letters
oh [__]
she'd really be taking a stand right now
foreign
wow he really buried the [__] out of
this
[Music]
goddamn right
I wrote a letter to you almost every day
on this ship
on my first side of the Africa Coast wow
that he seems like she led a much better
life do you know what a jungle is trees
they are so big they look like they were
built confines and Ferns and animals
wow she's really getting to use her
imagination why can't Tashi come to
school she asked me the olinca don't
believe in educating girls she said
they're like white people at home who
don't want black people to learn
after two months all we hear is chopping
and scraping and dragging one of the
boys in my afternoon class burst out as
he entered the road approaches the road
approaches
what a crazy production every Hut that
lay in the proposed road path was
leveled our church our school
my heart all went down in a matter of
hours
I guess it's not that much better sweet
Corey
dad from fever and grief oh my goodness
just pray
[Music]
don't keep me waiting for their joy and
escapism comes from reading these
letters man honey come out here for you
to take all day to shave me
and get the molasses out your ass
oh my God just cut his throat that's
crazy so is it like like reading the
letters living through the stories of
her sister will be her final push to her
surely standing up for herself and
getting her freedom
out of here
all right
put your head back
my neck itching like the inside of a
horse's ass
[Music]
foreign
good peoples huh Celia is coming with us
[__] yeah Over My Dead Body
that's what you want
now what's wrong with you you low down
dirty dog oh what
oh [__] this is really happening
you knew she was the only somebody in
the world who loved me
hell yeah
my kids they coming home soon
we all get together we gonna sit around
and whoop your ass
y'all was writing kids
made my life here hell
of course your daddy ain't nothing but
some dead horse [__]
on the life of the man
foreign
[Laughter]
thing you've done for me
I was feeling real down I was feeling
mighty bad
I know day is a God
goddamn
one penny in my money did I ever ask you
for anything I never asked you for
nothing not even your sorry ass hand in
marriage
[Laughter]
Uncle [__]
you going where
I kept going on riding this house pass
me them people
oh God this is so good all you fit to do
is be Shields made and you ain't even
that good of a cook anyway ain't nobody
crazy enough to marry you
do
that is such a prick any more lettuce
come
could be
you're poor you're ugly you're a woman
you're nothing at all did you do right
by me
everything you even think about gonna
fail goddamn right
it's been a pleasure meeting all of you
the dare you plan for me is the one you
gonna rot in
whoa everything you've done to me
already done to you
all she had to do was raise her hand up
against him
I'm here
God damn it she gets us here sister and
her children
[Music]
all the Shadows
foreign
[Music]
has passed
look how withered to the house
not even the mailbox can be kept
together
can't even shave come on it's time to go
now go home come on time to go now time
to go
I'm just gonna roll over and die it sure
is nice
see you too
together again
okay so you have any character here
first he's just really drunk my mama
married this dead man two years after my
real daddy dad
you as well
and he died
on top of me
oh
it's all yours now your real daddy on
this land
and he left it to your mama and when
your mama died it passed on to you and
your sister Nettie
I'll very much explained
[Music]
what
I think it pisses God off if he walked
by The Color Purple
in a field and don't notice it
okay it just won't be loved like a say
in the Bible
everything want to be loved interesting
that's why it's the color purple it's
the theme you
oh
oh so
sister what a cool spot yeah
[Music]
yeah be to me
fascinating
[Music]
oh everyone congregating
that's pretty cool
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
how fun
come on
make amends for Christ's sake
daddy Sinners have soul too
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's she coming home
is he about to do the right thing
two people lost away
that's right the immigration stuff in
Africa
[Music]
damn
it's the same actress this looks like
the same teenage actress
and they're running through the purple
she's doused in purple
this is your son
he says this is the day of his dream
this is Olivia
mama
[Music]
come back
I'm very attached
yeah he did it right by her
oh
foreign
[Music]
Ty used to go by Larry Fishburn alrighty
well I could talk for like nine minutes
because apparently a trailer just came
out uh or like an hour ago while I was
filming this and um it's one of the big
ones so I gotta hop on it you might be
able to match it with whatever this
video gets released with that trailer
with the way I'm looking right now I
thought this was a really moving film
very very moving I'm not familiar with
the time
um that this took place in but I thought
it was for the most part a smart film I
thought for the most part it was
poignant uh very touching I mean look
first thing I gotta talk about like the
performances all right Whoopi Goldberg
was phenomenal in this movie phenomenal
and it's pretty crazy I think what one
of the Testaments to how strong the
performances are in this film is
like I'm so familiar with the Oprah
Winfrey personality I'm so familiar with
the Whoopi Goldberg personality they
like she's become like a host you know
and viewed as like a comedian Whoopi
Goldberg and then you have Oprah who's
freaking Oprah she's Oprah Winfrey and
all I saw the whole time when watching
this were these two characters Whoopi
Goldberg's transformation from this
abused timid victim who evolves into
someone of true strength finding the
strength within herself and watching
this Evolution over time like I really
believe this time span that they did
Oprah Winfrey Sophia is just it's like
like the phrase that comes to mind for
me is she is like a force of nature I
thought she was so strong
so powerful and then you know you have
someone like uh Danny Glover who's I've
seen him in other works obviously
outside of the Lethal Weapon movies I
made a comment about it you know
Predator 2 villain and witness he's not
a bunch of films I haven't quite seen
him do a role like this though uh this
guy was evil and cruel early on in it I
did say like he kind of reminds me of
like a boyish bully like someone who's
like a boy in a man's body and then to
see that that is exactly who his
character was by the time you meet the
dad he is he is this person who is
taking out a lot of his own
traumas like there's a lot about the
commentary on you know not just like the
the systematic racism that is within the
the world that they grow up in but a lot
of these uh traits of upbringing
especially the toxic traits of
upbringing especially than the men that
I wasn't expecting to be explored I
didn't know what to expect my only
preconceived notion was that I I heard
it was like a a touching picture and it
was Steven Spielberg so that was
interesting
white guy directing it hmm wonder if
nowadays you can get away with that
doesn't matter Steven Spielberg he's a
phenomenal director I guess the thing
that kind of threw me for a loop that it
took me a bit of adjusting towards was a
bit of like the Hollywood gloss Sheen
that's sort of placed over it I kind of
just assumed because it's Spielberg and
then knowing that this might be a bit of
a like rough experience based on the
kind of commentary and subject matter
that I heard hints about that it would
feel a little bit more like like a raw
gut punch real and while there were a
lot of scenes that really deliver that
especially especially because due to the
very very strong acting uh there there
were aspects of its filmmaking that I
you could feel a bit of that PG-13 touch
versus going for like that hard R rating
that uh that this would have done but I
have to transport myself to the time in
which movie was made which on IMDb it
says uh 1985 so if this is coming out in
1985 I know this is like a film that's
considered a classic so I can imagine
that in 85 this this is a little bit
stronger a little more brutal like
nowadays I think if you were to do I
mean other than the version if we were
to do like this story today it executed
not the Broadway musical version that I
I think that's what the the new movie is
going to be an adaptation of but to just
do something that's based on the book I
feel like nowadays in the 2020s you
would want it to be uh something that
feels a lot more raw not to say this
movie does not have that gravitas of
realism laced throughout it uh there was
a somewhere in that cross between
because I finally I just saw Gone With
The Win For the First Time It's not
nothing like gone with the win but it
was still kind of captured in that that
area that era with capturing that like
that Wonder because that's the the odd
part to me the dichotomy of capturing
this subject matter
yet
um it still feels like it was made with
a sense of love I still feel like there
was so much care
and a passion to the filmmaking behind
it that even though at times that the
tone and overall execution didn't click
for me specifically in the first third
of the movie as the movie started to
really progress in the last two thirds
you know really it was around the time
when shook Avery came into the picture
uh oh Margaret Avery is the is the
actress and her last name is also Avery
Margaret Avery also phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal I thought there
was some Unique Kind of relationships
that I haven't quite seen done in any
movies especially the ones that they
draw between uh Celie and Suge that I
thought was very powerful as well I
think there's a lot of great powerful
moments in here and even for like the
character of Albert to have an
unexpected Arc I thought they were just
gonna end it off on him being like
full-on villainous and for him to even
have a realization which is you know
part of it is seeing who these people
really are underneath the surface and
letting that part of their soul shine
through and then even instantly a bit of
like that joyous hope and optimism at
the very end I did find uh quite fitting
actually so yeah I could see why this
movie has been able to it's not just
this movie but the story has been able
to overall stand the test of time
there's a lot of resonating themes in
here I think to this day I mean it's
from 85 I thought it was a 90s movie The
cinematography is still very much
excellent the production values are Rock
Solid I loved of the way all this was
overall like captured uh even at times
if the tone overall didn't quite click
for me but then at times it did work I
was surprised by how they had these
humorous angles in here at times it
would feel like it was Sometimes
undercutting some of the tension or the
or the the rawness of it where I could
imagine especially in like 85 like oh
this is kind of a brave story to be told
and it feels very authentic but I guess
watching it through today's lens at
times it would sort of feel like it it
might undercut a moment or two but then
at the same time you know for a movie
that does have all these things that are
like emotionally and physically abusive
in life even sometimes in the Harsh
Times there is still a sense of humor to
be captured overall action I'm like you
know what having some of that humor
because at times it did really make me
laugh and a lot of times the humor did
just shine through with the characters
it still worked for me I could hear
someone at the door and they're just
gonna have to wait that's someone being
John I would need to process it a tad
bit more there's so many things about it
that do feel personal and there's a lot
of things like dealing with like
cultural grievance as well at times uh
the melodramaticness some of the things
that could feel a little bit more
sappier self-indulgent when it could
have gone a little bit more
subtle because yeah it's two and a half
hours long and I didn't actually feel
the run time when I was watching it and
obviously there were some moments that
definitely brought me to tears uh I
think there's a lot of great I I don't
know if I quantify this movie for me
personally as this is a great film from
beginning to end but there's so many
like just great powerful scenes that are
laced throughout there's some just so
many strong things and I I would I guess
I did kind of crave it to be a little
bit more
a little bit more feeling in the Raw
real thing but I I also blame myself for
thinking that because
I that was the one thing I expected uh
from it just knowing that it was like
Spielberg and some of the other films
that he's done but then I'm like oh but
this might have been one of the from
knowing the films with that Spielberg
was working on at that time in like
1985. this might have been his first
Venture into making a movie like this
like after E.T at Indiana Jones you know
this is like his first attempt before
like 94 when he got around to like
Schindler's List and you know and then
doing like Saving Private Ryan things
that did go a lot more for that raw gut
punch uh but for the most part I think
the the effort and the performance is
all around like I think just for the
performances alone it's it's worth
watching there's still a lot of strong
stories with some gut-wrenching scenes
but overall a story that has a lot of
beautiful angles to it and a survival
tale as well like there's there's so
many things that they're dealing with uh
all in once and I think it's a it's for
the most part a fluid character
exploration parts of the execution
shouldn't feel dated but the movie still
feels Timeless if that makes sense so
yeah overall I still think the directing
was really good not just capturing the
time I forget what city they live in but
not just capturing the societal time of
that but also implementing uh the the
African culture we've been throughout
just this journey of of Whoopi
Goldberg's uh Sealy growing growing into
this human being over Time Left Me
overall with an emotional impact overall
I left very satisfied uh and man those
performances are so freaking strong I
was surprised by that I was I was so
surprised by like wow this this really
holds up and also another thing I give
it to for for a moment of this length I
do think the editing is actually really
really strong as well like you have to
really calculate how you're going to do
this so that way it doesn't feel like
it's dragging or Meandering and I
actually think that they did an
excellent job at pacing this movie so
while at times a little bit too much of
a gloss a lot times a little too
self-indulgent and sappy uh for the most
part though I never faulted the actors
for that it was more so some of more the
hollywood-isms behind it the
performances the direction the the
storytelling there are a lot of Brave
qualities to what they decided to do
with this giant bag of a lot of
different themes they are uh unpacking
all at once but overall I did leave very
much satisfied and still very much
impressed by a lot that happened in this
film so I'm glad I finally watched it
but guys what do you think about the
color purple do you love it is it one of
your faves I'd still put it in that
category of of those kind of there it
does have that feeling of like the
forest that's why I said zemek is like
Forrest Gump or like Amazon like
Shawshank Redemption around there but if
I think if this was willing to be
R-rated it could have been just that
much better for me but yeah
thanks nice sentimental time
alrighty well thank you guys for
watching and uh I will catch you all
soon
[Music]